he is the self- style protector of
Israel the man who would keep the
country safe where others failed
blocking threats from outside and within
in the years of led the state of Israel
it got much stronger he has painted
himself as the greatest Jewish leader
since Moses um this is essentially how
he has pictured himself when in history
he will be denoted as the very worst
leader of the Jewish people
Netanyahu used the security argument to
propel him into the role of prime
minister several times but now opinion
polls say 9 and 10 Israelis blame
October the 7th on a failure of his
government and more than 50% want him to
resign netanyahu's popularity is
shrinking and shrinking shrinking but he
believed that somehow he would turn the
table and would with his ocus Focus
magic will make the public once again uh
uh behind him really behind him his
standing in Israel has never been low
he's had problems before he's been
kicked out of office before the great
Survivor always seems to Stage a
comeback the latest just over a year ago
when he took control of the most
right-wing government in Israeli history
now the majority of the population wants
to see a different government a
different prime
minister the leading candidate would be
Benny Gant a member of the war cabinet
but a popular figure not part of net
party and there's y Leed the leader of
the opposition who said Netanyahu has
lost the trust of the people I think
that Benny Gans and youred bring a sense
of stability a lack of fanaticism a
de a rolling back of the religious
extremism that we've seen in Israeli
Society over the past years led by
natany and his
Coalition Benjamin Netanyahu insists he
is focused on on winning the war and
then the inquiries the inquests can
begin Benjamin Netanyahu once famously
said you may not like me you may not
trust me but I will keep you safe now
he's fighting a war in Gaza a war which
will determine his political Legacy and
how he's remembered by the history books
Alan Fischer alzer West
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer